how's Umbra's my name is Pippa my voice
is getting old and wispy I can't do this
anymore I can't do the high pictures
we're back I can just kidding just kid
don't you worry we were doing really
well in night three and then they really
give you like not much time from the
vent part to the light part I don't know
I thought I was kind of I thought I had
the situation under control but I died
anyway cuz apparently I waited too long
with something that makes me a little
poopy in my pants
but as a great woman once said if you
have poop in your pants you wipe it up
that's my mom who said that she was sick
of me having poopy pants
[ __ ] [ __ ] off [ __ ] up we're gonna do
this [ __ ] again like I don't know how
much I have to flash him let's just do
that I don't know I'm gettin tired of
[ __ ] flashing his ass that work or
yeah that work all right we'll just
flash him how about this we'll flash him
one letter for each letter in your ass
that sounds good
smart and beautiful that's how they
describe me and articulates that's it
that's holy damn it [ __ ] damn it how
am I supposed to flash him one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirty forty fifty is a
million in nineteen twenty twenty
alright twenty is my lucky number so
that has to work so the music starts
coming when he's in the middle it seems
to be the case at least and you hear
them where they come through the vents
so really we can just play around with
this music box all night
this game is fun look it's pac-man wocka
wocka wocka wocka wocka wocka wocka
wocka wocka wocka nah he's there now
damn it
why not black black there we go one two
three four five six seven eight nine 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 that's my
lucky number that has to work I worked
ah damn it what what are you tricking me
you [ __ ] with me baby
wait me I got it to you
the faceless Kluge the froggy the Frog
Frank froggy is this a new froggy game
I heard you it my [ __ ] where did
you come from see that was in two
seconds
hey I'm wearing see see I see
maybe I don't understand the game but
that seemed kind of [ __ ] to me this
is like hey you've been playing for
three minutes
well [ __ ] you and your three minutes
that's that's that's kind of how I see
it well at least in Dark Souls when you
play it's fair is your fault was that my
fault
what'd I do wrong and I flash enough I
knew he was coming through the vent I
don't know I don't know mine maybe I
don't
maybe I didn't pay attention to him
enough maybe I actually have to look at
them through the the cameras or some
[ __ ] ooh baby I love the way you were
gay I wanted some pie your ass and me
maybe he doesn't care that you have the
mask on because he doesn't have a face 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
I don't know why I have a problem to
count to 10 apparently 20 so the reason
why 22 my lucky number is because I'm
when I was a kid I was playing the
lottery on an amusement park which has
like stuffed animals kind of like this
game which is kind of funny and they had
the bunny a giant green bunny it's
called Liz super high men and I I don't
know if the wheel was [ __ ] broken or
whatever was up with it but I would win
every time on 20 I want like five times
in a row in 20s I walked home be like a
huge as bunny and like for tiny as
bunnies they are all right so I see you
now
like you can't [ __ ] me through this
like what is this game one for me I know
if I look away for like more than two
seconds I'm dead damn it I keep getting
I could technically get [ __ ] now
come on see how little time that is it's
[ __ ] scare me come on spook my ass
off so scared
come on it's not scary if I know the
jump scares coming see this is where I
think I started to dislike the game last
time because it gets more about the
challenge which is okay but I just think
it should be about horror if you're
gonna have jump scare it should be scary
the tension is high the tension is high
as long as the Balloon Boy doesn't [ __ ]
me I think we could do this oh god oh
god I just heard him don't [ __ ] me
Balloon Boy not at 4:00 a.m. maybe a
little earlier in the morning damn it
can you just go away like that would be
[ __ ] splendid if you could just go
the [ __ ] away this music box [ __ ] is
just pissing me off
I just flashed my flashlight in my yes I
said it
what you're gonna do about it I just
flashed my flashlight in my yes I did it
what you're gonna do about a bit
Oh God Oh God not not not no they
switched places the [ __ ] have
switched places I hate you you're not
gonna kill me at 5:00 a.m. all right
if you kill my 2:00 a.m. if you kill me
at 4:00 a.m.
you cannot [ __ ] kill me at five buck
in a.m. all right that's just not
[ __ ] cool all right I'm not gonna die
I got why is my flashlight down in the
bottom why I haven't even used it that
much all right we should be fine
ah [ __ ] me sent by now [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
come on I'm gonna be [ __ ] pissed you
are not you shall not ah 5:00 a.m.
did you did you hear praise the Sun did
you [ __ ] hear that did you [ __ ]
hear that did you hear that [ __ ] right
right and firemen oh my god I can't
believe I got that on kik hey you got
the crack cocaine or what pills which
Yemen I I don't know what to tell you
man get me back the crack cocaine I it's
me okay all right I'm gonna end it there
brother like and stay awesome hits the
sky tacoma birthday